your favorite ubisoft games might be
coming to mobile and ea might already be
working on another battlefield
ubisoft is developing a rainbow six
mobile game according to a report from
tom henderson the report claims the game
will be called rainbow six mobile and
it's apparently in development at
ubisoft in collaboration with 10 cents
wii game the existence of a 10 cent game
with ubisoft is no surprise as tencent
said during its last earnings report
this week that it was working with
ubisoft on multiple new projects the
first of these is expected to launch in
2023. the report said that the rainbow
six mobile game will be revealed on
april 6th and we'll report back with
more details as they come to light
rainbow six would be just the latest
major franchise to make the jump to
mobile as call of duty fifa madden apex
legends and many others have done before
the report went on to say that tencent
will also help ubisoft bring assassin's
creed and the division to mobile through
their own games which tracks with
tencent's public disclosure that is
working with ubisoft on multiple titles
going forward no details about these
rumored projects are available in other
shooter news pre-production has
reportedly begun on the next battlefield
game and we'll see the series revert
back to its familiar roots after changes
introduced in battlefield 2042 were not
well received according to a report on
xfire who previously suggested a
free-to-play mode maybe in development
developer dice has learned quote
valuable lessons from battlefield 2042
and will no longer be using that game as
the new foundation for the long-running
fps franchise one former developer who
recently departed from dice after the
launch of 2042 had suggested that the
next battlefield was at one point being
designed to be even more of a hero
shooter style of game it's claimed that
recent play tests and feedback sessions
were focused on the class system in
battlefield 2042 and this resulted in
these plans being changed so that the
specialist role will be tied more
closely to classes xfire also reported
that the next battlefield will be set
closer to modern day battlefield 2042
takes place two decades from now in a
world where climate change has created a
paradigm shift in society however the
actual game didn't live up to these
themes with cheery characters clean
looking levels and no further story
development after season one was delayed
as for battlefield 2042's future ea and
dice are still required to release new
specialists modes weapons vehicles and
maps as a part of its battle pass
obligations which is being handled by a
dedicated team within dice and now let's
talk about call of duty warzone's
original map for dance because it will
not be coming back at least not anytime
soon ravensoft creative lead josh bridge
said on tp's recent stream that while
the studio would like to be able to
bring verdance back alongside the new
map there is a technical issue
preventing this from being possible
according to bridge each time activision
has done a massive update that requires
a big download the game has lost players
because people simply don't want to
spend the time downloading another big
file for dancing not returning isn't
that big of a surprise though as raven
said back in april 2021 that verdansk
was gone for good and would never return
looking ahead the developer said that
activision is putting more effort into
technical optimizations for warzone to
allow for big updates without such
massive downloads so do you dream of
reuniting with verdansk let me know in
the comments below i'll see you tomorrow